[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
está más Romero sala aquí en el estudio
de directo América marque Buenas tardes
nuevamente con usted aquí compartiendo
este espacio de salud y hoy vamos a
hablar de historia porque la semana
pasada se expuso la que se cree fue la
primera cirugía al menos la que se tiene
registrada Buenos días un gusto volverte
a tener aquí con nosotros y
efectivamente estamos hablando de la
amputación de un pie se descubrió en una
tumba de la isla de borneo en la parte
de Indonesia de la isla de borneo y se
Data está Pues esta tumba entre 31.000 y
30.000 años hace tanto tiempo entonces
básicamente lo que se sabe es que se
amputó el pie hay una parte de la pierna
por encima del tobillo tanto la tibia
como el peroné los dos o huesos y además
se sabe que esa amputación sucedió
cuando la persona todavía no era un
adulto y que además sobrevivió entre 6 y
9 años después de la amputación por lo
tanto fue una cirugía totalmente exitosa
es un descubrimiento que cambia mucho
como pensamos en los orígenes de la
medicina y de la salud Porque se creía
que estos orígenes de este tipo de
intervenciones tan complejas estaban
alrededor de hace 10.000 años no en la
revolución neolítica cuando las
sociedades pasaron a ser sedentarias
empezó la agricultura no unas formas más
complejas de estructura social Pero en
este caso pues se trata todavía de
sociedades cazadoras recolectoras por lo
tanto pues es una cosa que ha roto un
poco los esquemas de lo que se creía que
son los orígenes de las cirugías Cómo se
sabe mal que el hueso fue amputado por
el corte efectivamente muy buena muy
buena la intuición básicamente se ve un
corte como oblicuo y muy limpio que no
cuadra con un accidente o con un ataque
de un animal o con una fractura no los
cortes Así que son accidentales Ahora
solo suceden por accidentes con metales
o en accidentes de coche por ejemplo y
en ese momento pues el Metal no existía
no Entonces es un corte intencional por
y además no hay señales de infección que
esa es otra de las cosas que decíamos no
como el conocimiento siento que se
requirió para manejar esto la herida
además también pues sano bien y eso
tiene muchas implicaciones uno pues
reconocer que las personas que la
efectuaron en ese momento sabían que la
persona para sobrevivir necesitaba ese
tipo de intervenciones ella es un
conocimiento médico bastante avanzado
dos también conocimientos de anatomía de
los músculos de los vasos sanguíneos a
ver cómo dónde hacer el corte para que
la persona luego por ejemplo no se
desangrara también conocimientos de
fármacos o productos naturales que
ayudarán al manejo del dolor y también a
la prevención o al combate de las
infecciones y además pues la
recuperación en esas condiciones y en
ese momento de una intervención así
requiere muchísimo cuidado y no solo eso
sino que se ve también por una cierta de
generación de los huesos En esa persona
en las piernas que no debía andar mucho
y en esa topografía y en ese tipo de
vida que además decíamos que las
comunidades no son sedentarias el
cuidado comunitario social que tenía que
recibir esa persona para sobrevivir a la
operación pero también para seguir
viviendo esos años después pues es muy
alta y por eso decíamos que puede
cambiar un poco Cómo percibimos esas
comunidades su complejidad su estructura
social alrededor también pues de la
medicina y también recordar eso no como
esa medicina esa cirugía como una señal
también de lo que nos hace humanos y de
la civilización increíble y además que
pues eso estaban como yo dices tú muy
evolucionados como otras civilizaciones
que pues en muchas ocasiones y
menosprecian no seguimos con la historia
porque hubo otro hallazgo que explica
una parte muy importante de nuestra
evolución humana si hoy estamos en una
capítulo histórico de la salud que
además ya sabes que me gusta
especialmente es un estudio de la
revista nature que básicamente estudia
un cambio genómico entrenar dentales y
los humanos modernos de hoy en día para
que nos hagamos una idea el área el ADN
humano tiene aproximadamente unos 20.000
genes de esos hay 97 que nos diferencian
a los humanos de hoy en día a ti y a mí
de los neardentales es muy poco menos de
un 5,5 pero contienen mucha información
y se han estado estudiando desde 2014
cuando hubo el primer genoma neardental
que se pudo descubrir el protagonista de
este particular estudio es una mutación
en gente ktml1 que parece que gracias a
esta mutación se pudo desarrollar mucho
más el cerebro humano no tanto en tamaño
porque recordemos que el tamaño del
cerebro en neardentales y en humanos
modernos era más o menos el mismo pero
en Cómo se organizaba sobre todo en
crear más células en el lóbulo frontal
que es el que se relaciona con el
pensamiento complejo Que pues nos
diferencia de muchos de nuestros
antepasados hicieron expresar esta
mutación en humanos en Perdón en humanos
no en ratones en tejido celular cerebral
y también en células madre hasta
desarrollar una especie de organoide de
cerebro para ver qué pasaba Y en todos
descubrieron que cuando había la
mutación había más células neuronales
cuando no había la mutación había menos
qué aplicaciones tienes que hallar Pues
para mí la primera que quisiera destacar
es esta belleza no de la historia más
antigua dándose la mano con algunas de
las técnicas más modernas que existen
hoy en la ciencia y en la salud pero en
general Además de eso se ha considerado
un gran paso en empezar a dilucidar este
misterio que es la evolución humana
algunas por ejemplo reacciones
recopiladas por Science media Center de
España hablan de lo asombroso que es que
este pequeño cambio nivel genómico pueda
tener este nivel de consecuencias Por
otra parte también ha habido otras
opiniones por ejemplo la de Emiliano
brunero una investigación un
investigador sobre evolución humana
también en sciendes media Center que
dice que las conclusiones son demasiado
generales para un proceso tan complejo
como es la evolución pero en cualquier
caso definitivamente es una pieza más en
este rompecabezas mar como siempre
Gracias por toda la información
referente a nuestra salud como siempre
un placer compartir esta mesa de trabajo
con usted pasamos